sova bonjour l'opération escargot a déjà
commencé sur le périphérique parisien
oui l instant on vient d'arriver sur le
périphérique vous le voyez nous sommes
dans un autocar pour suivre cette
opération au plus près vous l'avez dit
environ 150 autocars se sont rassemblés
d'abord à vincennes avant d'entrer sur
le périphérique des chauffeurs
d'autocars qui viennent de plusieurs
régions de france donc pour faire
entendre leurs revendications
ce qui se passe en fait c'est qu'ils ont
eu des reports d'échéances de crédit
notamment pour une période d'un an à
l'époque c'était donc au mois de mars
2020 lors du premier confinement on
arrive donc au terme de cette échéance
ils craignent donc qu'ils doivent
maintenant reprendre les versements de
crédit alors que leur activité elle n'a
pas repris vous l'avez dit une baisse du
chiffre d'affaires de 80 % sur le
secteur touristique en 2020 pour
certains d'entre eux s'il ya certes un
mois où il ya zéro activité puisque
évidemment les groupes de touristes ne
sont pas très nombreux en ce moment à
paris et sur l'ensemble de la france il
n'y a pas non plus de voyages scolaires
par exemple ce qui leur permet
permettrait de garder une certaine
activité je propose d'écouter quelques
unes de leurs revendications de leurs
témoignages sont au micro de julien
guitare dans notre corps de métier on a
des frais très élevés comme les
financements des véhicules à partir
d'aujourd'hui à partir de la fin mars on
va devoir reprendre le financement de
nos véhicules qu'on a pu reporter
jusqu'à aujourd'hui d'un an mais
aujourd'hui les banques nous refuse
catégoriquement le report et à partir de
demain va se retrouver à payer des
grosses trêve de trois quatre cinq mille
euros par véhicule par mois donc en vue
multiplié par le nombre de véhicules ça
fait des grosses sorties d'argent
on a essayé de discuter et d'obtenir en
fait que nos frais fixes qui s'élève en
fait à 20 % 20 % et 20 % qu'on a déjà
dont 40%
on a démontré qu'il nous fallait 40%
pour pouvoir survivre puisque comme je
voulais dit on a commencé à réellement
touché le fond de solidarité en décembre
donc nos pge en fait ont servi à vivre
de à partir du mois de mars jusqu'au
mois de décembre est donc aujourd'hui si
on a passé 20 % dans 4 mois 6 mois les
entreprises de transport routier de
voyageurs sont mortes ou posent tous le
bio dépose tous de bilan et c'est fini
ses fans nos activités faut savoir qu'un
autocar dans lequel je me trouve coûte
environ 350000 euros et évidemment il
perd de la valeur au fur et à mesure du
temps et il ya donc des considérations
financières et c'est avec ces pour ses
revendications que ces chauffeurs
d'autocars veulent être reçus par le
premier ministre ou du moins par un
conseiller à matignon c'est donc la
raison qui les a poussé à organiser
cette opération escargot menée
actuellement sur le périphérique vous
peut-être sans doute entendre les bruits
de klaxons on va parcourir 2 km depuis
donc vincennes jusqu'à la place
jacques drouin f c'est à proximité du
trocadéro pour espérer pour que les
autocaristes espère ensuite être reçus
par une délégation ministérielle
merci merci beaucoup thomas bonnet pour
toutes ces précisions